prenez note de mes volontés avant que je
ne disparaisse monfils
dorénavant c'est vous le roi
[Musique]
mais le troll doit être transmis un
héritier mâle hakim
il semblerait que vous ayez un fils
retrouvé le préparer le chat royal
repartons numérique c'est hors de
question votre majesté
ça va
on chante encore
[Musique]
quelle joie de vous revoir
merde alors millions un petit exploit
qui s'annonce salée kunta kinte
hezbollah leurs familles les groupes
d'iphone salman délai oui les bb crème
la pop sous couvert de mouches -o
à ce niveau c'est pas possible de dire
des horreurs pareilles sur le bébé qui
crèvent de faim je vais demander de
quitter mon foot politiquement incorrect
qu'est ce qui vous amène ici au terroir
[Rires]
[Musique]
m